bienvenue à arlon
certains d'entre nous sont nés ici
s'il vous plaît essayez de respecter
cette ville
c'est bizarre ici et j'avais su que vous
aviez venir je ne serais arrangé un peu
la banque est devenue propriétaire de
cette maison il ya plusieurs mois vous
ne devriez plus être ici
tout va bien menti retourne dans ta
chambre
c'est le dernier de mes pensionnaires
le laisser seul il ne peut pas vivre en
société vous comprenez
c'est pour ça que je ne peux pas en
athlétisme
allez viens
ainsi doucement qu'est ce que vous
faites
c'est lui n'est ce pas je ne crains
aucun hommage
les airs fesses
don carlo est une ville fantôme yes men
où on voit ce qu'on peut en faire j'ai
pas envie de vivre si c'est n'importe
quoi cette idée c'est une opportunité
pour pouvoir se lancer dans un endroit
où il n'y a pas de violence pas
d'hystérie
en sécurité
or vous êtes les nouveaux voisins c'est
ça
[Musique]
je suis pas le lis tu étais tu es
d'accord
[Musique]